did did somebody I mean do you think
other events in the past like you know
the scene with Weaver on what happens in
Waco where you're going back and forth
and you you bring up BOSU ball has some
kind of a trust after the shooter killed
his wife you know were there other
experiences you you had that led you to
being prepared for the negotiating with
David Koresh and if yes what were some
of those well yeah I worked a lot of
cases before the 1993 Waco incident so
you know the FBI's whole curriculum in
terms of negotiations was you know it's
part art and part science I mean the
science is to get people to cooperate
which is our goal we need to establish a
relationship a trust so that's the
scientific part we we know the
requirement and the goal the other part
is a bit of art how do you do that how
do you project your sincerity and
honesty and genuine people like to work
with people that they like and respect
so I mean you get what you give so you
know those are sort of the parameters so
when we dealt with the David Koresh we
knew we had responded to an incident
that resulted in a terrible shootout
between the ATF a different agency and
the Branch Davidians the Koresh LED and
we knew that there were dead people
there was wounded people there was great
emotion there was you know a great bit
of anger and frustration one side versus
the other we had to we the FBI
negotiation team we had to come in and
sort of separate ourselves and try to
project that we were sort of a neutral a
mediating entity you know that hey we're
not the ATF and we don't pretend to
understand all the issues that are
important to you but we want to learn we
want to see if we can work with you so
that we can avoid further bloodshed and
we can get this resolved peacefully and
that's what we did the first half of the
Waco incident we got 35 people out
including 21 children a fact that's
often overlooked and I'm very proud of
that it's unfortunate that that thing's
digress
you know after I left the scene but
yeah that's that's kind of our goal so
yeah I think we were well prepared to
deal with the David Koresh but we had
other internal disagreements in the FBI
that I'm sure we'll talk about in this
interview and certainly discussed in my
book I guess the biggest thing is you
know prior to a negotiating with David
Koresh who was did you have a scenario
like one that's you know like for
example you talked to a Michael Jordan
or you talked to a Adelaide Kobe Bryant
or you talked to a Brady or some of
these guys in sports they'll sell you'll
say so tell me the toughest opponent you
ever faced and yes well you know I hated
playing against you know Joe Dumars I
hated defend against this guy who was
the toughest person you faced off pree
David Koresh that you were both you know
excited with the results that you got or
one where you said I wish I wouldn't
take him that approach in a negotiation
were there any on both sides that you
remember
yeah there's two that stand out and I
talked about both in my book one was a
case in the 80s in Virginia where a guy
kidnapped his former common-law wife and
child and from Connecticut and drove
them to Virginian we located them in an
in a remote farmhouse and and I ended up
negotiating with him for some ten hours
now he was a very dangerous guy there
were times where we communicated quite
effectively but his controlling nature
over his former ex-wife and child made
him a high potential for lethality we
were pretty certain he was going to kill
her and possibly himself in the child
suicide often follows a homicidal act so
it was a huge challenge connecting with
him so he was one of the toughest cases
I've ever worked with and in fact we
ended up I had to negotiate him out of
the house on his hopes of getting to a
helicopter where an FBI marksman took
his life the other case was also in the
80s and was on a train in in Raleigh
North Carolina an Amtrak train a guy was
a drug runner and he was traveling with
his sister and her two small children
they were sort of his disguise and he
end up having an argument with her and
shooting and killing her the train was
the cars were detached in Raleigh and
negotiations set forth this was
extremely challenging because he only
spoke Spanish he he was one of those who
was almost afraid to communicate with us
for fear that we would hear the fear in
his voice that we would psychologically
get into his head or whatever it was and
at the same time we had children dying
of dehydration and one of them did die
so we had that clock ticking against us
on the one hand and on the other hand we
had this challenge of of an effective
communication channel you know it
ultimately worked out that he did
surrender we saved one of the two
children but it was an extremely
difficult case he subsequently died in
prison but those two standout I think in
the area you talked about Patrick as
being extraordinarily challenging ones
that I dealt with you know well prior to
Waco
[Music]